voici l'unité des grands brûlés du
nouveau chum
une fois par mois alexandra duchesne
vient comme bénévole rendre visite à
quelqu'un qui a besoin de parler ça leur
donne l'espoir de voir que tu continues
arrive à prêter sur est une personne
normale puis comme l'heure j'ai pas la
brûler en ce moment la jeune femme de 24
ans koné les précautions à prendre
il veut aider d'autres grands brûlés
j'étais vraiment prête mentalement parce
que les plaies ouvertes et pansements
les vêtements compressifs ça me pape a
rappelé tournée c'est que le souper
qu'elle préparait le 17 mai 2010 est lui
a laissé de mauvais souvenirs
manger me la mitaine écusson j'épluche
dont une enfant star iv pour le jeter
dehors mais au même moment on a fait un
face à face dans le cadre de porc fois
que le chaudron d'huile mesures exposées
tu puis en même temps j'ai pris en feu
parce que ie un coup de vent puisque un
an quand le chaudron pow pow blessés
maroc en plus moi j'ai été brûlées
troisième des griffes sur le bras droit
celle que stone elle
le chaudron puis 2e décrit le score sa
soeur et elle se sont retrouvés au chum
elles avaient toutes les deux besoin de
greffe de peau le prélèvement fait sur
sa cuisse pour soigner son bras et ce
qui a été le plus douloureux pour
alexandra montreux intégré c'est comme
ça on voit plus tellement que la crise
est belle mais il était optimiste mais
blessure allait bien géré mais
l'apparence en général c'est quelque
chose qui à l'écran paul ayant de la
difficulté loin c'est sûr que c'est dur
après c'est vraiment c'est le regard des
hommes au chum les grands brûlés arrive
au neuvième étage sans passer par
l'urgence 700 c'est vraiment ce qui peut
pas avoir la température très élevée
tout de suite
donc pour éviter d'en voir perdre du
temps peintures de plus avec comme le
lit ce très spécifique pense que l'on
peut ériger la plaie on veut nettoyer la
plaie tout de suite je suis infirmière
toujours parce que ça front des
infirmières spécifique vraiment connaît
le brûlures commun qui on peut traiter
les brûlures
l'unité a son propre bloc opératoire
immense il y a neuf chambres environ 150
patients sont hospitalisés au cours
d'une année c'est la douleur les
familles c'est l'image de soi c'est sait
beaucoup de choses c'est parfois c'est
un acquis si souvent des accidents bêtes
donc les gens se sentent un petit peu
pris là dedans puis on a une passion qui
viennent de partout du québec
quelqu'un qui vient de val d'or c'est
très difficile à gérer point de vue
familial
les besoins en soins et services sont
énormes des plasticiens au psychologue
en passant par l'ergothérapeute qui a
d'ailleurs suivi alexandra je pense est
une des choses qui peuvent aider le plus
les patients
voulu aller dans la douleur
malheureusement parce que dans les
exercices ya toujours un peu de douleur
ou même si on a la médication donc mais
elle a été très volontaire pour
alexandra et sa soeur marie fini la
friture à la maison les accidents
arrivent en tout temps mais le temps des
fêtes est propice à ce genre de
mésaventure